hello good morning we start with
breaking news emergency services in
berlin say at least one person has died
and around 30 people are injured after a
car drove into a crowd on a street in
the west german capital police say a man
drove into a group of people but that
they do not yet know whether it was a
deliberate act and that the driver is
being held at the scene
well the actor john barrowman and his
husband scott gill are in berlin and
they saw what happened and they're both
able to join us now
and john and scott thank you very much
for joining us
john just tell us what did you see
well we uh at about 10 o'clock this
morning we decided to go
buy a couple of t-shirts and shirts and
things to scott's going to a wedding i
we're going we're going on vacation
beyond here we came out of the store
i heard a noise while we were in the
store and we came outside to see
police just zooming down the road
there was a cafe across from us that had
all of the chairs
barreled over and people were they were
smashed through
it was a i think a renault clio silver
one that had then gone looked like it
had driven into the window now we saw
inside
we thought that uh
it was an accident because it was inside
the store
so we started walking our way up the
street and it was about two city blocks
that we walked up and then the police
just swarmed and we saw
the dead person in the middle of the
road covered
um where we had dinner last night uh
where you're looking right now um on the
corner there to the on the screen on
your right the viewer's right hand side
we had dinner over there there was a lot
of casualty that
people injured over that area were being
focused on by the emergency services i
saw a woman being putting in put into a
uh
an ambulance they were uh looked like
they were resuscitating somebody they
were uh right there
was where it began it looked like and
they came on the pavement the person
came on the pavement
by the levi store in the bank drove then
onto the street hit the person and
killed them in the street
then came back onto the curb went down
the curb through the
through the um
uh the cafe area and then into the
storefront so it's like a two
city to three city lottery areas
of distance and
when when it happened my friend mikey k
got on the phone and you guys sky news
no mikey he called me and he just was
calling to say hi but he said
immediately to us get behind a tree get
behind something in case there's a
secondary wave so while i was doing the
videos and scott was filming we were
standing behind a tree to try and make
sure that we were
protecting ourselves but
how
horrible that this morning these people
got up to just go through a regular day
that they were going through their daily
business i mean we were shopping we're
okay
but if we'd if you think if we'd have
come out of that store
one minute earlier and i you know we
would have
anyway that's beyond it but it's just it
is we can say from what we see and i'm
we're not experts but
this was this looked intentional this
looks intense it looks intentional by
the way the car went on the pavement off
back off onto the street and back on
again yeah yeah
and and
then
in terms of that you're also suggesting
that it was quite a big area that this
happened over you were saying it was you
know a couple of blocks you saw one
casualty quite a distance from where the
car actually ended scott
uh we could see from the kaiser wilhelm
church which is right by the europa
center it's the kind of pub of west
berlin
and we could only see from the kaiser
wilhelm church 300 meters down the
street to uh
we've got the name of the road
so crashed on the corner of marburg so
just down from going eastbound from the
cooldown into the front of
clothing store
right in it was right in the window and
the doors were open so if someone had
been dragged out
but there were chairs and tables smashed
on the pavement and um
just a trail of destruction you could
see the current zigzag on and off the
pavement on the way down there's 300
meters when we were doing the
the posts and the pictures uh
because i figured right away
we let my parents know we're okay so to
my family we're okay scott's family he's
okay it's just
i've never seen anything like the kind
of carnage like that before with
i mean it just it's something i we were
walking back to the hotel and i said
scott did you ever think that we would
be
in the middle of something like that and
it's you know so it's quite awful but
the emergency services are there they
started pushing us back
um what about we they're doing like when
it first we were able to walk right into
the scene because they were too
disorganized they were concentrating on
saving the
people who were injured but gradually
before them began to get expanded they
were pushed away
but for the first 10 to 20 minutes it
was just sheer chaos they were
energizing it just keeps expanding
concentration on the victims obviously
and so we
walked right through it without really
realizing what was happening
it's obviously a really distressing
thing to witness are you guys both okay
yeah we're we're both by just a little
bit
quite shocked i've never seen um
what's dead what do you say anybody just
lying in the middle of the street
ever
and also that to see that
i mean i i'm
sorry just to see the the uh
just people hurt and people who are
innocent and senseless destruction by
whoever has caused this whoever's done
it i mean horrible
a horrible horrible person and these
people were just going having breakfast
at a cafe
it's just awful just i mean just vicious
vicious vicious vicious thing to do
you sent us a you you posted some images
uh and sent in some video let's just
show them 12 years now because we're
showing you the pictures from the agency
at the moment but uh these are some of
the pictures that you posted earlier and
you could you can see the the emergency
service response they obviously got
there pretty quickly because you said
you heard the you heard a noise um and
then when you came out the emergency
services were there so so thank
mercifully a pretty quick response
yes
in fact i heard the
we were in the store we were it was
there's an uniqlo across the street and
we were in the store and we heard i
heard the smash
and that would have been about 10
10 30
and then we were out of the store by
about 10 35 10 40 because that's when we
took the first that picture you're
looking at now that's when we took that
at about 10 40.
so it was a 10 minute period but then we
heard the sirens and then the
helicopters and everything were it was
just
i mean there was three helicopters there
when we left one which uh we posted the
footage of which was planning to airlift
somebody out but
they were doing obviously taking care of
people who were injured and the the poor
person who was in the middle of the
street was just left there so
but yes it was um
it was within seven minutes that the
emergency services were there very very
quickly they were very quick
and in the the street that it was on is
it was apparently also the same street
that the the christmas truck attack
happened back in in
2016. in the same area
i'm really surprised that you say that
because yesterday when we were walking
after dinner we were walking down the
street where you know this is you're
looking at now and i said to scott
they've got all these bollards up on the
pavement that must be to stop people
you know someone attacking and driving
through the crowd i had no idea that was
the same place one of those bollocks you
see was just smashed through the car
careered into one of his cars and it was
exploded onto the street onto the
sidewalk it was full of sand just waited
down the sand and that was next to where
the person is
for the kaiser wilhelm church
it's just at the end of the first and
down so
if you can go back can you that footage
that you have right now can you pull out
a little bit to see the
the street a little more because where
that police van is
um i don't know if you can tell the camp
so where that police van is the the
ballard that scott was talking about
that was exploded
was right in front of that van
the large policeman with the blue
flashing lights and then the person's
body was right there so they've cordoned
it off so nobody could see yeah um
yeah that's really interesting isn't it
that clearly there were safety and
security
measures that have been put in place
retrospectively since that that attack
but it possibly appears that
if this was a deliberate attack that it
it that they didn't didn't manage to to
stop it entirely
no no and it was um and that was you
know part of the reason we ate over
there last night just right there in the
center of the shop under the street
where you see the trees uh by the levi's
store just to the left we had we had
dinner there
last night and we felt and that was
literally where the car was across the
crowd would have crossed from right to
left on the screen there on the other
side of the road so for the viewers
watching from your right to the left the
car careened across
on the pavement went across the road
came onto the road on the other side of
that pavement and that's where it took
the the gentleman or the person sorry i
assumed
that incorrectly the person
we don't
no yeah we don't we don't know who was
driving that car and what was the on the
street itself it appears relatively calm
from the images that we're able to see
there at the moment but presumably it
was pretty chaotic when you came out of
that shop there must be a lot of very
very
terrified people
it was it was chaos when we were we
realized that
it was interesting when we we thought
the car was just an accident when we
started walking up the street we saw
more cordoned off tape i said to scott
this is something is wrong and then he
said well
i said look they've cordoned off the
next junction and then they've cordoned
off another side
suddenly realized the scale was just
getting bigger and bigger and so i then
immediately
i mean the first thing i did was i
called i i uh
uh i called i called my mom and dad to
let them know i was okay and then scott
has spoken to his parents but we knew it
was something bigger than just an
accident because of the
the scale of it and also the where you
were looking where the the
levi store was
that was where
i saw the most of the injuries that had
happened because there was a lot of
emergency services focusing on people
who were on the ground
uh get people were getting
sorry there's more
emergency services going by there was
people uh getting up off the ground
limping away and and just being taken to
uh ambulances and to fire trucks there
was it was i mean there was a helicopter
landed next to us
where the car crashed in the shop front
obviously went through some tables and
chairs outside the uh outside the store
there so clearly somebody had to be
airlifted from the the final part where
the car went into the storefront window
and i think you have a bug you got you
have footage of the helicopter don't
yeah yeah yeah
anyway it's it's not what we wanted to
wake up we were having such a lovely
time and we were sharing it with all of
my uh my fan family on on social media
as we do with all our vacations and
everything we do and um never did
sorry never did i think in my life that
i'd be in the middle of a terrorist
attack
well it's a really terrifying thing to
to have witnessed um and we really
appreciate you talking to us about it um
listen guys we'll let you
have a moment uh collect yourselves
maybe maybe have a cup of tea will be my
advice um stay safe and thank you so
much for talking to us on sky news we
really appreciate it and thank you for
for sharing with us the images of what
you saw this morning
thank you we're glad to help
it's just be careful out there because
it was a horrific act
john and scott thank you both very much
we appreciate it thank you